a day of sorrow and promises of
vengeance
president joe biden and first lady jill
biden attended a solemn transfer
ceremony for 13 u.s service members
killed in thursday's suicide bombing at
kabul airport
their remains arrived home in
flag-draped cases at an air force base
in delaware
five of the dead were 20 years old just
babies when u.s troops began fighting in
afghanistan after the september 11th
attacks
their lives lost in the final chaotic
chapter of america's longest war
biden has pledged that the u.s will hunt
down members of the group that claimed
responsibility for the kabul airport
attack the president will stop at
nothing to make isis k pay for the
deaths of those american service members
at the kabul airport he will ensure that
we get the people responsible for this
after killing two senior isil k members
on friday another u.s drone strike
destroyed a vehicle outside kabul
airport on sunday
the pentagon said the car was carrying
isil suicide bombers preparing to target
the final stages of the u.s military
evacuation
with tuesday's deadline approaching the
u.s and 97 other countries say the
taliban has committed to keep providing
safe passage out of afghanistan to
foreign nationals as well as afghans
with travel authorization
we've rallied dozens of countries from
around the world to stand with us in
saying to the taliban that if they do
not follow through on those commitments
there will be significant consequences
and with a new government taking charge
officials say the u.s will continue to
strike at groups and individuals it
deems to be threats in
country after country including places
like uh like yemen uh like somalia uh
large parts of syria libya places where
we don't have boots on the ground on any
kind of uh ongoing basis uh we have the
capacity to go after people who are
trying to do us harm will retain that
capacity in afghanistan
u.s national security adviser jake
sullivan says that groups like isil k
operating in afghanistan do not have the
capabilities to carry out attacks in
other countries
at least not yet
rob reynolds al jazeera washington